in relationships for a man it should be
how to be a good leader there are men
there are men nowadays who
they don't know how to at the very least
plan the day they'll just ask the woman
I don't know what do you want to do
because because they're pleasing yeah
but I think it's because women sleep
with men without going on dates
so they don't like I think men do what
they're expected to do and a lot of men
don't have to do anything
you mean are you saying that men don't
have to try very hard because there's
always women available who will yeah no
I'm saying a small percentage so most
one out of three men are virgins are
haven't had sex in the past year anyone
who's like at this space knows that stat
but um like a very small percentage of
men
don't plan dates because they don't need
to because girls are like so readily
available to them they can go on Tinder
they can go on Instagram and a girl will
be there quick yeah so I think sometimes
it's like a reflection of the women
because like that's like we accept that
yeah it's it's on both right so it's on
the man where they have to know how to
at least be a good leader and plan the
day but it's also on women collectively
to raise the standards so that the man
planning the date becomes a norm not an
exception but it's like I think we if we
raise the standards we have to raise the
value too and it's tough because we're
just not what men want anymore like the
average age of one
that's not that's not Youth and and what
how what percent of girls at 31 are
virgins
none zero and if they are they're not
and then we've got two free kids on the
way or they're already you know yeah so
it's like
I don't know it's just kind of it's like
I always hear like women say raise your
standards but if you don't have to be
this done right but a lot of times like
we try to be the we try to raise our
standards after the value's gone because
women women need to protect the value
that we're given
or men have to create value and that's
what needs to change is more women need
to know how to be the standard that
they're setting for the man do you think
of birth control went away tomorrow how
do you think that would change the
dating Market
I don't think it'll make a difference I
don't think it'll make a difference
people just pull out yeah that would
make a difference I think inflation is
way too high right now
women would be a lot more selective
about who they have sex with if they
accepted it they wouldn't just go
marching on it wouldn't happen it
probably wouldn't have happened straight
away but over time women would become
more selective about who they're
sleeping with but I think ways of what
it is off putting and what does happen a
lot of men the first thing that they do
talk about is sex and it can be
off-putting for women and women has to
say like you know do you know what I'm
not doing this like if you don't want to
get to know me or take me out on a date
let's leave it because I'm not not
taking that and then men have a problem
with that some men have a problem with
that I will say well you know even men
in their 30s oh yeah oh well you piece
of prayer even in their 40s you
I don't I don't think most men start
with that I think a lot of men are
afraid of getting kids
no no there is a lot of men that are
like that no maybe not a lot of men that
are in a social media platform but there
is a lot of men that still act like that
that still behave like that that still
expect to have that that's basically
they need to have it
um I win a women's challenge that say no
I'm not interested or not even having to
say anything just ignore them because
you're like what is this I waste of time
a waste of energy how does this start is
this like online or if you just have an
example it could be online yeah it could
be
um a person could approach it speak to
you about I don't know it could be
anything and then all of a sudden I'm
like oh yeah um what knickers are you
wearing really so so on the street so on
the street a guy will just come up to
you and then ask you what knickers
you're wearing sometimes yeah well not
even knickers
there are men out there this is
very interesting like
is that is that your experience
not really I do get you know the
occasional cat call of the hole like oh
what's your number like you're beautiful
but I wouldn't say I've gotten some
super provocative things no like I said
I might not personally will get that all
the time but I will witness it or you
know social media I've had it sometimes
where I've had to block certain men but
it happens what's worse is it worse on
social or is it worse in person
I think in both I think the world that
we live in right now and I think because
of covid and everything can lock down
and people just got more enticed with
social media and internet everything
like people don't know how to talk to
people people don't know how to
communicate people don't know how to
approach a person people don't even know
how to have a phone conversation yeah
just text me everything's text voice
note no I let's have a conversation
let's see if we can actually speak for
five minutes and I'm still enticed in
the conversation yeah that'll be that'd
be a nice challenge exactly if social
media went away tomorrow how would that
impact dating
I think it would improve it after a
while yeah you've got so much choice now
yeah it's just there's always a nicer
new person around the corner so you
might as well keep swiping I've never
done online do you no and I never would
people would have to be more selective
wouldn't they and they'd have to be more
more intelligent more sophisticated
about the way that they men would have
to be more sophisticated about the way
they approach women and women had to
pick better so if you went to the bar
you couldn't ask one girl out and then
go ask another girl out and then go back
to the first and say all right okay you
have to pick the one you wanted
and that was the only one selection yeah
you have to scan the room for a good 10
minutes to see which one you want to
talk to because you know yeah
all right
well I I think more men would approach
women in public and like maybe social
skills would improve yeah because you
don't have that option and to avoid
rejection I think women too yeah like I
said before you see everyone would go
out more yeah yeah before I had laser
eye surgery I was technically ugly to
like 99 of women right
remove my glasses grew my hair all of a
sudden I'm attractive and I'm six foot
plus so it doesn't matter if I've got a
mattress on the floor you're still
coming home with me
you don't know that fact until after the
fact and even then I'm cooking you
breakfast in the morning so she you're
coming back for round two because you
like breakfast in the morning forget the
mattress on the floor yeah you love me
but you don't have to be the six-figure
guys to get to get to to run the
crutches
you get crutches if if you apply
yourself yeah I just think if those like
I feel like a lot of problems will be
solved if literally we got rid of birth
control on social media wow yeah because
because women would have to be more
selective with who they sleep with yeah
I mean like maybe you know you said pull
out but like since they actually have
what do you think is the biggest
challenge for women when it comes to
social media and what they see on a
daily basis
um I think it inflates like women's ego
so like I think a lot of times we think
we're hotter than we are right that yeah
so that's your point pal I feel like
there's a date in inflation going on as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible